the president-elect also will get the
presidential daily intelligence briefing
starting today
that'll be the first time since his
election comes at a very tense moment
right after iran's top nuclear scientist
was apparently
assassinated over the weekend holly
williams looks at the challenges the
biden administration will face in the
middle east
there's been an outpouring of grief in
iran for nuclear scientist mossen
fakhrezadeh
gunned down in an ambush last week
iran's president hassan rouhani blamed
israel for the killing on saturday
though israel hasn't commented president
rouhani said his country would take
revenge in due time but wouldn't fall
into a trap
that could be a reference to hopes in
iran that president-elect biden will
rejoin a deal
that gives iran's sanctions relief in
return for restrictions on its nuclear
activities
president trump withdrew from the
agreement in 2018.
at this base in iraq used by american
forces to coordinate
airstrikes they told us their threat
level hasn't
changed the pentagon announced this
month that troop numbers in iraq would
be cut by
500 just before president-elect biden
takes office
general ryan rideout told us it won't
impact
operations i think we're capable i don't
think you'd see much of a difference i
guess
but critics say it could give a boost to
militia groups
backed by iran that have fired scores of
rockets at u.s
targets this year alone
and across the border in syria the fight
against isis
still isn't over this sprawling camp is
home to more than sixty thousand
displaced people
on the ground the 82nd airborne division
is patrolling the desert
it's thought thousands of the extremists
are still at large
the point of these patrols is to stop
isis from coming back
and gaining a toehold in villages like
this one
lieutenant colonel val morrow told us
they're trying to persuade locals that
the u.s will stick with them
in the struggle against isis we're not
going away
until they're gone is the bottom line
but following president trump's decision
last year to open the door to an
incursion by turkey into syria
some locals told us they're finding it
harder to trust the u.s
tony the situation will be monitoring
holly williams for us holly thank you
very much